how everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to let's play missing the
distant Island this game is also in beta
so keep that in mind it is not
officially released it's way early so
don't make any judgments about it
there's a nice website you can click
link in the description so let's get
into it control mouse controls your
eyeballs WASD controls your footsies
left mouse button controls your camera
oh well it's definitely on an island
it's a lot brighter than I thought it'd
be let's wander out in the ocean till we
die oh no it won't let us okay this guy
moves fast look at him go hello you
birdies hello I don't know why there are
some crows on the island here seems
awfully strange you're not native to
this habitat
oh it's getting dark like fast Sun stop
you'll move almost a trance as I do
actually it's not that I'm that moves
it's a you should take a picture as
evidence what why it's getting late you
should turn your spotlight well that was
Jesus that was like really fast okay
right mouse button turns on the
spotlight why are they even here how did
I even get here this doesn't make any
sense
Oh resent moon hurry up moon damn you
crows go to sleep nighttime oh okay this
is like this is like super hyper speed
this is like playing the sins always and
max speed something is going way too
fast I need time to take in the
environment some weird tropical
environment with crows and dead bodies
and an ocean I can't swim in and I
wouldn't be surprised if slender
appeared from out from these trees
oh oh stop that
no I don't want any please go away
spoon visiting dog near moon the map
disappeared I'll [ __ ] your moon move
oh I'm moving that's a stupid moon how
the hell am I supposed to know where I'm
going
maybe I was not with my like oh shut up
crows this is not the place where you're
supposed to be none of this makes any
sense there's a thumpy thump out there
somewhere
I got a jar adorned okay I see a path
here wait where'd the path go well here
it is
I'm gonna follow this path hopefully
it'll lead me somewhere interesting out
on a path oh yes it is a path maybe it's
not I can't tell hopefully it'll leave
me somewhere interesting usually in
these horror games follow the path
you'll usually get to your death but I'm
gonna risk it I'm gonna assume this is
leading me to another dead body the dead
body it's later too as my own I'm gonna
I'm the dead body
oh okay probably not a big surprise so I
am going to take this topic I don't know
what's doing that away hang do I hear
something jingling in the distance
anything
the the the woods are a bit more dense
here selling a good look nope nothing go
back to the path
nothing nothing nothing he wasn't dense
at all what was that like I came out of
nowhere he didn't really do much but
good oh my throat okay you can go away
you can have right off buddy wherever
you are that you did you that's probably
plan I still haven't found any more dead
bodies Hey well what are you I've gotta
get right run
don't look at or else it charges he's
still following me
good go away turn off my life for a bit
just a few seconds here just my camera
now I go I don't know if there's like a
recharge mechanic or anything
nono nono nono nono nono nono nono nono
nono nono well oh I found a path again
til nobody's take random pictures
everywhere ran to pictures taking aa
bigger run turn out your light bono
fusion of origin go hey I hear you got a
Lhasa Bella treads
no that was bull that whole game was
bull not the game itself but my game
that I was playing there my session I
was all oh such ball look bull okay let
me play again hello hello don't tell me
okay there we go okay
right they say I didn't even read that
okay let's run quickly take a picture of
his body
click like a lubbers up okay now we move
really quickly because the Sun is moving
down oh god this island is gigantic
oh sought out son son
slow down seriously son son Jesus son
got none of that body okay
whoop up I wouldn't have even seen that
ah son start up I need to get out of the
obligation I'm on here Lu
I lost the path where'd the bass go bath
is gone
well I'm it's about time this guy got
tired he's been booking it like maybe
the game developer heard that I
complained about all the previous
protagonists that weren't able to run
for two feet okay calm down there buddy
it's not that bad yeah okay now I'm
picking off to normal speed again let's
not let's only sprint when there's a
monster here bye okay followed the path
I need to find seven bodies and
apparently they're all in the same place
so it shouldn't be too hard to find him
click 'ok numbnut follow the path woo
what are these no thank you
I can't climb up on one bull is this
evidence whoop no apparently not okay
whatever you say buddy this sure looks
like some important evidence to me or
are these just oil tankers there's got
to be like a dead body or something here
pretty morbid when I'm like gotta be a
dead body oh man I'm so disappointed
there's no dead body oh man aw that
sucks bro okay whatever let's just try
to avoid the monster uh was that a dead
body yes I'm so happy I've heard of that
body yeah yeah I got money I'm ready
true with me yeah dead body poke it with
a stick
go away monster go away monster
where'd it work Jesus I keep getting
turned around know this okay here we go
I thought it was a dead end to the path
I would have been very upset haha dad I
already have this evidence up poopy Oh
No i looped around the island already oh
the other ones prior no what the hell
oh it's a bird take a picture of the
bird evidence
yeah whatever shut up who's chata I'm
not here bird-watching I'm here monster
hunting or monster running
I'm monster fronting I don't know tree
evidence Boop nice picture that looked
good on my fireplace tree evidence Oh
poop ah man such high-quality contrast
ah so good the composition look at the
lines well poop rule of thirds oh man so
great where were you
I know just a different dead body what
oh come on take a picture take a picture
oh nice pose buddy nice pose I got
another one yes
that's four of seven I'm never gonna
find the other three never ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever hmm I
keep think he's gonna pop up in front of
me
a little Oh today ah don't look at it
run this way ha ha ha
is that a [ __ ] what is this a sign
isn't gonna be yeah I read my door that
let's not get all preachy heavy
I said a [ __ ]
if accent apparent fry every time it's
an icon you're like ah and I'm done I'm
done I don't want a t-bird
oh boy I don't want to play there's no
way I'm gonna find all the dead bodies
there's no way that's impossible but the
game is really good I like it a lot I
mean it's still the whole collect X
number of things mechanic but at least
it's more interesting like you know I
don't know what it is it's pretty close
to slender mechanics but it's just like
a different evolution of it and I kind
of appreciate that because you gotta
take a picture instead of just
collecting it he appears in front of you
every time you like goes off I mean it's
pretty cool not everytime so you never
know so but either way it's really well
made I like it a lot so check it out for
yourselves click the link in the
description below support the website
still in beta remember so it's not the
final product so thank you all someone
for watching click the invasive more
videos
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
now
thud